[Music]
disney movies can be enjoyed by people
of all ages
however some of its content gets funnier
with age
not sure what we mean by that well by
the end of this video
your view on disney humor might never be
the same again
here are the 10 items disney failed at
being disney
and believe us when we say that number
one
will shock you for days on end new
around here
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up
okay now let's get right into the top 10
times disney was
oh so inappropriate merida's parents
if you're a fan of 2012's brave you've
probably watched the disney movie more
times than you can count
however depending on how old you are you
might have missed some inappropriate
scenes that were targeted at the older
generation at the beginning of this film
we see a young merida learning to shoot
her brand new bow and arrow
the king of dunbroch is proudly watching
his daughter load her arrows
while giving her some pointers but the
same can't be said about queen eleanor
after running out of arrows
merida is sent to retrieve hers from the
woods and
once at a comfortable range the queen
pounces on her husband
to reprimand him for gifting a princess
with a bow
but before she has the chance to
schooled him the king smacks his wife's
backside
and starts giggling like a madman this
subtle moment is hardly ever noticed by
children but is
instantly caught by adults this
hilarious scene isn't something that is
typically showcased in disney movies
but producers saw fit to add it in their
script in a way
this might be disney's way of showing us
that king fergus and queen eleanor
have a happy marriage even though they
have very different personalities
from where we're standing it looks like
king fergus knows how to avoid being
scolded by his wife
zootopia's gory moment if there's one
thing disney movie has
it's a core message that can teach you a
thing or two in 2016 the film zootopia
hit the big screen
and people from all over the world
crowded the movie theaters
this movie takes place in the animal
kingdom however it's completely
different than the one we're familiar
with
instead of living in forests jungles and
trees
our favorite animals inhabit a
human-like world and take on
everyday tasks like going to work and
fighting off stereotypes
zootopia revolves around a little bunny
named judy
who is determined to become a police
officer in the big city
the problem is rabbits are considered
prey animals and don't usually land jobs
in the crime fighting department during
this film
judy brings us back to her childhood and
shows us a play
she created to explain how the animal
kingdom used to work before
animal rights kicked in she teams up
with a tiger to put on a show her
audience will never forget
to say that this scene is obscene would
be an
understatement especially since young
judy went all
out in the blood department during her
show the tiger swipes at her belly
and she begins pulling red ribbons from
her midsection she then goes on to throw
herself onto the floor and squirt
ketchup out of her side
the look on her parents faces is more
than enough to know that she went
a little too far really i'm guessing you
don't have much experience with heat
nope aladdin in a brothel there's no use
denying it
disney's aladdin is riddled with some of
the most offensive lines we've ever
heard
with so many vulgar moments to choose
from we had our work cut out for us
one of the most surprising lines in the
film is heard at the beginning of the
song
one jump ahead a guard spots aladdin
stealing a loaf of bread
and while chasing him he yells i'll have
your hands for a trophy street rat while
his words are sickening to hear
many other scenes make them fade into
the background one that you may not have
noticed
occurs during the very same song but
three arabian women wearing
flashy colors camouflage it in this
scene aladdin comes soaring
through the window of a brothel however
many of us never realize that
to make matters worse the workers know
aladdin by
name and comment on how sad it is that
he's hit rock bottom and doesn't have
money anymore
by the end of this scene the brothel's
manager chases him with a broom
and he jumps out the window with a
lustful look on his face
these events are easily overlooked but
they're present nonetheless
well done disney well done ursula's last
scene all
ursula ever wanted was to become the
mightiest sea dweller who ever lived
unfortunately for her her success was
short-lived
disney's little mermaid is by far one of
the most successful movies in its
repertoire
so much so that its franchise received
three installments
regardless many of us would agree that
the original little mermaid was by far
the best
after striking an impossible deal with
princess ariel
ursula bewitches eric to fall in love
with her while her witchcraft proves to
be useful for quite some time
her spell is eventually broken but this
doesn't stop the wicked sea witch from
obtaining her much desired trident
after uniting her forces with the
trident ursula becomes big and mighty
and begins
wreaking havoc on everyone around her
unfortunately for her
prince eric manages to sneak onto a boat
and direct a massive
spike into her midsection ursula gets
surprised by the blow
and immediately sinks into the sea while
screaming in
agony we don't know about you but this
scene freaked us out as children it's
hard to believe that disney animated
such a violent scene
instead of leaving her demise up to our
imagination we never thought we'd say it
but we feel sorry for ursula human stuff
huh
hey let me see
[Music]
tarzan meets jade growing up in the wild
can severely
impact your social behavior skills
especially if you were raised
by apes when tarzan first laid eyes on
jane he couldn't believe what he was
seeing
and can you blame him after all he'd
never seen another human being before
that very moment
to keep his identity secret tarzan
watches jane from afar
that is until she has a run-in with a
herd of baboons
at this point tarzan rushes to rescue
jane and helps her escape from her angry
enemies
after bringing her to safety tarzan
starts to get a better look at his new
friend
and it's evident that he likes what he
sees disney is supposed to be for
children but every once in a while they
target their humor toward an older
audience
while this is hilarious it's a classic
moment of disney
failing at being disney in this scene we
see tarzan getting closer and closer to
jane
he starts examining her toes but then
quickly moves on to look under her skirt
she kicks him away and looks around for
help clearly uncomfortable her
awkward state is heightened when tarzan
places his head on her chest
despite her warning him that he is close
enough
all in all this unpleasant scene shocked
many of its viewers
but hey give tarzan a break he was just
getting to know jane the way nate would
have
anna punches hans like most people all
princess anna
ever wanted was to love and be loved in
return
well she might have gotten her wish but
it didn't pan out the way she thought it
would after meeting someone who
seemed to be her one true love anna's
sister elsa
ran away from home determined to bring
her back to arendelle anna chooses to
leave her betrothed tans in charge of
her kingdom
this proves to be a big mistake
especially since hans turns out to be
frozen's big bad guy
when anna realizes that hans is nothing
but a big fat phony she does
everything in her power to save her
sister turns out the love she always
wanted
came in the form of sisterly love and to
preserve it she sacrificed herself to
save elsa's life
anna's heart froze once again but this
time there were no trolls to bring her
back to life
thankfully anna survived the icy
encounter but no thanks to hans who
literally conspired to usurp the
arendelle throne
after all was said and done anna and
hans ran into each other on the docks
but this time anna wasn't going to let
him get off so easily the princess
punched hans in the face so hard that it
sent him flying off his ship
and into the icy waters when you take a
look at the scene in slow motion
you see just how much damage ana did to
han's face
which we'd say is pretty darn
[Music]
you impressive this fellow big summer
blow out
frozen's foot size moment when it comes
to disney's frozen
it's pretty obvious that the film is
jam-packed with sensitive adult humor
however children under 13 years old are
unlikely to find
any of these jokes funny because well
they just don't understand them yet
after meeting a traveler named kristoff
anna tells him about the beginning of
her journey and why she left arendelle
in the first place
as she's spilling the beans her newest
travel buddy can't seem to get past her
first sentence
which reveals that she got engaged to
someone she just met
determined to make her realize that her
sister elsa was right to freak out over
her engagement
kristoff starts asking anna questions
about her fiance
during a quick round of questions
kristoff ends up asking on about hans's
foot size to which she replies size
doesn't matter
this tidbit of information is quickly
covered up with more questions but for
the most part viewers notice the
inappropriate
reference cinderella's mice cinderella
was raised to treat
everyone with respect and kindness
however the same can't be said about
lady tremaine and her two daughters for
the longest time
cinderella lived with her widowed father
whom she loved very much
unfortunately her life took a turn for
the worst when her dad chose to marry
lady tremaine after his passing the
young girl was turned into a servant by
her evil stepmother
and quickly realized that her life was
no longer hers to live
on the plus side though cinderella was
lucky enough to have a handful of good
friends
sure they came in the form of mice and
birds but this made no difference to
cinderella
in one scene we see jacques and gus
searching cinderella's home for buttons
fabrics threads and jewelry you see her
little friends want to make her a dress
that she can wear to the ball
the problem is they encounter lady
tremaine's wicked cat on the way back to
cinderella's quarters
and are forced to improvise when their
beaded necklace breaks
jacques starts to thread the beads
through gus's tail
while his rounder friend gathers them
into his hat
while this scene might look innocent
enough it's another classic example of
disney failing at being disney if you
don't see what's wrong with this image
you might have a eureka moment in a few
years from now
the flashing headlights lightning
mcqueen was used to getting everything
he wanted
but his life took a strange turn causing
him to wind up in radiator springs
this town was unlike anything he'd ever
seen and he soon found out how it felt
to be treated
like everyone else if there's one scene
we couldn't help but make a face at
it's the one that included mia and tia
these twin red cars
rushed to the gates where lightning is
being photographed and they urgently
explain
that they are his biggest fans then out
of the blue
mia and tia's headlights go up and flash
at lightning and to our big surprise
the car says ah i love being me
this hilarious scene took a lot of
people by surprise
especially since most of us wouldn't
expect disney to put something like this
in their film by the end of this segment
police cars
rush mia and tia off the stage and the
girls scream
we love you lightning as they're being
reprimanded by the cops
how about yellow no not yellow yellow
and snow oh
no jeannie's honeymoon joke some jokes
aren't meant for children but they're
still put in emotion because writers
believe them to be
hilarious despite disney being meant for
younger adults
they usually fail at keeping their
content pg
so you've made it to the end of our
video and want to find out which disney
moment is in first place
well you've earned it in aladdin and the
king of thieves
aladdin and jasmine are finally getting
married however their wedding takes a
turn when a thief with pointy claws
pokes an elephant in the butt
at this point the elephant takes off
running toward the ceremony
and his big steps alarm the crowd
looking slightly afraid
genie bends down and says i thought the
earth wasn't supposed to move until the
honeymoon started
although easily missed in the
action-packed scene genie was
insinuating that aladdin and jasmine
would be doing the deeds sometime soon
which is unbefitting
of disney in more ways than one despite
disney's many issues with keeping things
kid-friendly
we can't help but chuckle at their jokes
which disney moments surprised you the
most
let us know in the comments and that's
the end of our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]